you know one of the only cases from
history that I think you can't explain
with you know Chinese lanterns or some
other types of Mis identification would
be like the 1561 Nuremberg case where
they so they literally thought they saw
a sky battle take place and you have to
wonder if there's like type three and
two civilizations out there maybe there
is a Star Wars type battles that have
happened and you know some of that stuff
is debris that's floating around it's
it's asteroids some maybe some of that
stuff's Fallen to Earth and landed and
and you what would have happened over
history if say you know
some the Roman army found something like
this where would it where do you think
it would be today and where it would
have ended up
hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast I have the distinct pleasure of
sitting this afternoon with Jeremy riss
also known as alien scientist
he is perhaps a bit obscure to most of
you I have been following his work for
years I initially encountered him
in the landscape of what our
colloquially known as conspiracy
theories and what set Jeremy apart was
his scientific approach for every
conspiracy theory that he believed in he
seemed to debunk a dozen and I know that
conspiracies exist I am pleased to find
anybody who deploys a proper scientific
toolkit in sorting the wheat from the
chaff and so in any case I've been I've
been watching him from afar more
recently I've been paying attention to
his work on so-called uaps or UFOs as
those of us who have been watching this
space for years formerly called them
and I've invited him on Dark Horse to
talk to us primarily about the UAP
question are we being visited by
extraterrestrials have we been in the
past should we expect some sort of
contact between us and them in the
future so Jeremy without further Ado
welcome to Darkhorse
thanks for having me Brett I am I'm a
big fan of the podcast
awesome so I'm not sure quite where to
start here I will say
um most of my audience is probably not
terribly familiar with the UAP question
they've of course read stories in the
mainstream press and uh like me don't
know exactly what to think about them
I'm certainly
cautious and the reason I haven't
ventured down this road very far
is that so far what I've seen has the
feel of a psyop to me this feels
terrestrial in origin which does not
mean that I don't believe that there are
extraterrestrials with advanced
technology in the universe in fact
evolutionarily speaking the fact that we
exist suggests the likelihood is very
high that there are many other such
civilizations but as for whether or not
they've been to Earth I'm a skeptic and
I thought you'd be the guy to help us
sort it out
it's an interesting question when you're
dealing with
um you know when we study things in
nature we tend to use blinds and as many
scientists who are studying this
phenomenon has pointed out how do you
study something that's studying you and
doesn't want you to study it
and this perhaps technologically
thousands of years more advanced maybe
it's you know you know so and uses
invisibility cloaking and stealth
technology that's Way Beyond what we
have
um
so that's this is this is a good
question about whether they exist or not
and whether what we're seeing out there
is actually them because if it is them
then they obviously want to be seen as
long time listeners will know Heather
and I spent 15 years teaching in an
experimental educational environment
it was one of the most rewarding
experiences of our lives and that is why
I am so excited about the sponsor for
this episode Ralston College
Ralston college is a new institution of
higher education with Jordan Peterson as
its Chancellor
it is currently accepting applications
for its one-year Masters in the
humanities program
that program begins with two months in
Greece with immersion study of ancient
and modern Greek on the island of Samos
with visits to Olympia Ephesus Delphi
and other sites in the ancient world
after Greece students continue their
educational Odyssey in beautiful
Savannah Georgia with a
multi-disciplinary curriculum featuring
philosophy literature art music and
architecture
this is a once in a lifetime opportunity
and admissions are now open
there are a number of full and partial
scholarships available
for more information please visit
ralston.ac
Darkhorse that's
r-a-l-s-t-o-n dot AC
Darkhorse if you're ready to do the hard
thinking our era demands
right I was kind of I was gonna say
exactly that to the extent that the
modern UAP version of whatever is taking
place is happening uh those entities
want to be seen whether they're
terrestrial or extraterrestrial
um whatever cloaking they have is
obviously not working because we have a
large number of Highly credible reports
people have certainly seen something
yeah this is there's a number of cases
the Battle of Los Angeles they fired
anti-gun turrets in anti-aircraft guns
at this thing for hours obviously
there's there was something there
um some people suggest it was an early
form of this uh projection technology
that they were using multiple spotlights
as well
um it was in the Hollywood Hills in
California so they had a lot of these
spotlights that they China in the sky
back then and so they had them all
pointed up at this object and they feel
like that some somehow that could have
created a um a hologram effect
and and that's indeed how I believe they
created the Tupac hologram on the stage
they used like a smoke machine and three
projectors to triangulate the uh the
Imaging and
um so wait wait sorry I'm Gonna Keep
slowing you down because I wanna I I
really want to understand this
my impression in the modern version of
the UAP question
the thing that stands out to me most is
that you have what appear to be objects
they appear to be moving through the
atmosphere
at speeds that are improbable without an
apparent
um
means of propulsion which could of
course just mean they use some other
kind of propulsion but the thing that
really doesn't sit well with me
is that they don't
appear to make
a tremendous noise that the displacement
of air
is you know who knows aliens could have
technology that would cause the air
displacement to be neutralized in some
way that we can't understand but if
they're not bothering to cloak
themselves visually
it's a little hard to understand why
they would be doing that and I'm even
doubtful that it could be done that
effectively
or whether it's whether it's being done
by them at all or whether these things
are man-made altogether and that's one
thing that's missing from a lot of the
mainstream conversation is the
technology side of this
and the people that that the mainstream
if you do get the technology side of
this anyway you ask anyone in any UFO
conference how UFOs fly and your answer
is going to be element 115.
um and it almost seems like they've
poisoned the well on the scientific uh
you know physics side of this anyone in
the physics community that wants to get
into UFOs is sort of hit with this you
know oh God this is just not something I
even want to associate myself with
um scientifically or academically
whereas if you really get into the
science like in those awesome
dird reports that's the defense
intelligence reference documents you can
search that on Black Vault and and come
up with some of those files you get into
the real cool stuff like metallic
glasses for example which have
elasticity and strength Beyond you know
Carbon Fiber Beyond uh steel and and
other things then and uh you talk about
metamaterials which are used in cloaking
devices and invisibility Shields and
um also apparently in some of these warp
drive skins allegedly in the terahertz
range
um
interesting stuff you find and then you
get I was looking into terahertz and
what scientists were working on
terahertz and the classified terahertz
and found oh here's a guy that was
working at Wright State University right
next to Wright-Patterson who brought a
bunch of you know work home with him and
uh got a year in prison for it because
it was classified related to whatever he
was doing that the U.S Air Force was
apparently you know
funding or interested in because they're
the ones who showed up and busted him
um so you find interesting cases like
that which I I kind of I don't think
anyone was reporting on that story it
was out there in the news and they had
broken it the first news report actually
was from you know Fairborn Ohio and it
was
um
it said that they busted the guy for a a
marijuana grow and then like the story
changed it wasn't really marijuana
plants it was classified documents and
that was just kind of the throat you
know people off the trail
um but the real story came out and um I
I picked it up and I don't know if
anyone else picked it up or really
talked about it but um I thought that
was an interesting connection because it
kind of verified well at least they're
doing classified research related to
this you know maybe it was a maybe it
was a setup or a plant but that's I
don't to get a guy to do a year in jail
that's kind of hard for a psyop so
um well I mean yes and no that you look
it's not hard to come up with a proof of
concept of how you might get somebody uh
willing to spend a year in jail either
they've got something on them and it was
a better deal than he might have had or
um you know obviously
uh most people will have their price and
uh anyway it's not hard to imagine how
it could be done I'm not saying it is
yeah yeah just go look at look down it's
hard to you know look down the
conspiracy Rabbit Hole sideways at some
of this stuff
um because can I uh can I back you up a
bit though there's something that you uh
you breezed by there that I think is
important for us to discuss
uh and you you just feel free to correct
me wherever I've got this wrong slow me
down because I'm just I go off on this
stuff I've been doing it way too long
yeah uh yeah you're you're in deep
um with respect to things like
propulsion technology
um a I should say uh my brother Eric has
obviously been active in this discussion
uh and one of the things that he points
to is that the crossing of large
distances which is the number one
obstacle presumably to any advanced
civilization getting here might actually
not really be about propulsion at all
that it might be about space and time
not functioning in the way that we have
come to understand them and that it
might be possible to cross large
distances without actually Crossing them
and this is necessary I'll just point
out
that our galaxy itself is a hundred
thousand light years wide light which we
understand to be traveling at the
fastest speed possible takes a hundred
thousand years to get just simply across
the Milky Way let alone to anywhere else
and you know so that means that uh you
know light that we are seeing from the
other side of the Galaxy started its
Journey 90
000 years before humans started farming
right okay how long did it take the
light to get there from the photons
perspective
well an interesting question and believe
me uh we are almost immediately out of
my depth
um mathematically and physically I I you
know to be honest it's never better bad
misconception of it and the idea is that
if you can focus a number of your
photons on another point in space time
uh is from the photons perspective is
that those points are entangled and the
pilot wave interpretation of the abomian
interpretation of quantum mechanic says
that that those waves travel forward and
back in time and and then then decide
which way to go
um so uh we we are out of my depth but
let's just say
um the
we can black box the question of how an
alien intelligence might have found
itself in proximity to Earth and we can
put aside skepticism
uh with respect to whether or not they
could be here at all because there may
or may not be mechanisms for crossing
those large different distances on time
scales that sound
um reasonable to us and if they exist
then the things that are seen here on
the earth side of that Journey
are not likely well again out of my
depth but are not likely to be whatever
it is that cross those large distances
they would be Local transportation
is that fair or am I just
yeah I think like within an atmosphere
maybe the long the vast distances of
space if there's nothing in between
um they might be able to do uh some type
of a warp drive where you are able to
entangle to another point in space time
and then shrink the distance between
using the quantum entanglement but the
um for at least short distances there's
plenty of other technologies that you
know some of the stuff wasn't discovered
by Phil Brown effect discovered in 1928
was classified for 90 you know 80 years
uh 2008 Obama Declassified it along with
a whole bunch of other stuff and it you
know very quietly
turns out the B2 Spirit bomber uses a
version of this where they positively
charge the front Leading Edge of the
wing and negatively charge the exhaust
stream and it helps with
um lift as well and propulsion as well
as the radar signature and invisibility
of The Craft
and
uh but this has been used for a number
of years and see in programs including
you know by Ames Research facilities you
know in the 40s when Brown was trying to
sell this idea to the military and they
told him he was crazy and that and you
know his idea was was there was nothing
to it but meanwhile Amos was went and
stole the idea and was using it in the
X1 to um positively charge that that
nose cone that Needle on the front end
of the wingtips and the and the nose
cone and uh when they positively charged
that it created this like ion Cloud
which would deflect the bow shock on the
front end of The Craft so when it went
supersonic it wouldn't rip apart and it
was a key component of uh how they broke
the sound barrier and that it was it was
Brown's technology
and then Brown came back again in the in
the 50s 1956 with Andrew bonson in North
Carolina with bonson labs
so you have bonson bringing Brown in and
a number of other researchers came and
visited including you know Bryce and
Cecil do it from the nearby University
in North Carolina Chapel Hill the father
that the husband and wife team that um
your brother talks about
um on Joe Rogan and stuff so so there's
a number of these cross pollinations
that John Lear uh actually John Lear
senior
was there in one of the one of the
slides that's uh you know John lear's
dad who's
the guy that the CIA pilot who broke the
story at Area 51 and basically was the I
don't know he's like the grandfather of
the the Bob Lazar Legend in my opinion
which
that's a whole nother Rabbit Hole well
let's figure out how to address this so
so far I think what we've
concluded is
um there are superficial limits to
travel over long distances there's lots
of reason to wonder if there might not
be mechanisms that would bypass those
limits so uh could there be an alien
intelligence visiting the our planet
there could be we can't rule it out
um
if there is it is presumably
either never was and it's recently
arrived or is no longer interested in
completely disguising its presence so
the question of the blind is the blind
is lifted if what we are seeing that is
being described as uaps are in fact
related to something extraterrestrial
um I and you tell me if you share this
but
I am uh extremely skeptical of the
wrecked observations of these very
rapidly moving apparent aircraft within
or craft within the atmosphere in large
measure because they do not create the
uh
Sonic Booms for example that one would
expect when something moves faster than
the speed of sound within an atmosphere
as a result of its impact on just the
displacement of of air
and what wouldn't do that
is a projection let's just say
from above maybe if you had something
projecting
onto
particles in the atmosphere uh you know
water particles let's say there's also
laser induced plasma effect proton beam
that they can use anything that can
excite they cross the beams and the
point the beams cross so there's enough
energy there where actually can create
like a plasma in the air and the plasma
would allow you to project something is
that the idea so there's you can project
you can also dot matrix project like 3D
images by by patterning uh where the
dots where the dots cross in the air and
okay so to to connect the dots for for
viewers and listeners
the idea is
it is very technologically difficult to
imagine craft that can move through the
atmosphere at incredible speeds even
more difficult to imagine craft that can
do that without creating Sonic booms
what makes this
much more tractable from both the
perspective of the speed at which things
travel and their failure to create the
usual Sonic
consequences of a craft moving through
the air would be something like
uh laser pointer right if you put a
laser pointer you put the dot on the
ground for your cat there's no uh
meaningful limit to how quickly you can
move it across the floor because a tiny
movement of your fingers moves the thing
feet
and so were somebody interested in
projecting something that appeared to be
an object onto something like plasma or
water particles in the atmosphere or
whatever it was they could then move it
incredibly rapidly and the prediction of
that hypothesis would be that it would
not have Sonic consequences right no it
would not yeah you would you would not
have a sonic boom with that and for for
the audience if they want to look more
into this the technical term the
military uses is eccm or electronic
counter counter measure and the term
that um
you can look up to find the video on it
is is can it's a pentagon
uh talking plasma grenade or
um talking depending on talking plasma
balls should find a video on it you can
find um some of those Declassified
videos on it and and some of these
Declassified videos that other people
are finding through foia are going back
to some of these companies from you know
20 years ago you know or longer that
they may have had this so you got to
think in the in the 1960s when they were
developing lasers at Q division which
was a lot of the stuff that they did at
Q division still classified what would
be the first thing you did you would do
as a scientist after you built two
lasers
yeah sure
um okay so let's now talk about things
that don't fit this model okay I can
think of a couple you will know more if
they exist one is
radar signatures
um and the other is I've seen one video
which I have to say at the level of
the Deep fakes of other things that I've
seen I can think of no obstacle you
couldn't no obstacle to faking this at a
video level but I've seen one instance
where a craft appeared to have an impact
on the water that it was traveling uh
slightly above now that is not predicted
as far as I know by moving the
equivalent of lasers uh project images
um they could be a missile and certain
uh the advanced missiles that they're
building now including Torpedoes yeah
employ a new type of Technology called
super cavitation and the way that they
do this is through a directed energy
um actually that they use like a a
focused Mazer that focuses
um a microwave that that heats up air or
water in a pocket
um at a Target at a focal point a couple
feet or inches however long in front
with whatever they've calculated is the
optimal focal point but in front of the
nose cone of The Craft and when they
direct that energy there
um it basically super cavitates the air
or water in front of it so it creates a
vacuum
forward
pulls the missile forward it yeah pulls
it can pull the missile forward but it
also it also eliminates the sonic boom
because there it's it's crap I don't I
don't know that it makes a noise still
but it's not quite as loud as a sonic
boom because of the how it it's
eliminating the air so the air doesn't
it doesn't tear through the air and
create the same turbulence effects
afterwards that I see so if these were
objects moving at high rates through the
atmosphere is it possible the sonic boom
could be canceled
if you had this uh type of super
cavitating technology with these lasers
and
NASA started developing this in the
1980s
um out of out of um Rensselaer Polytech
Institute uh under a guy named Dr Lake
Marabou
l-e-i-k-m-y-r-a-b-o and he was the the
head scientist on it there's a number a
number of other patents you can look up
if you look up blasting air in front of
hypersonic missiles
got it that will give you an article
that you can find all the patents and
and um stuff on on okay so
um I think where we are is there's a lot
about the modern observations of uaps
that is most easily explained as
projections that can move at an
arbitrary velocity without displacing
air
are possibilities for how the natural
consequences in air might be partially
or completely canceled
so far I haven't heard anything I mean I
you know my cynical take as a a couple
more things for the people to they can
look up um I interviewed a guy named TD
Barnes that's Theodore Barnes he's the
head of uh special projects out at Area
51 for about 40 years he worked out
there and he seems to think that all
these Pilots are seen is and I asked him
this in the interview twice he says that
there's they're seeing are spoofing
technology it's it's our lasers and our
eccms and and these capabilities that we
have what's an eccm that's the
electronic counter counter measure
and he in an interview I'm also on the
drive he talks about project Nemesis and
project Palladium which is interesting
because project Palladium was a system
of these Balloons with the radar
reflectors inside so they were actually
these Pilots that were reported lately
seen a cube inside of a sphere
it's actually not a Cube It's actually
an octagon an octahedron inside of the
sphere but the the um the octahedron
inside the sphere is is in the patent
from Project Palladium and they go back
to like 1947 the patents on these things
that they've been building these and
they're radar reflectors and the radar
reflectors are what is called drfm
technology that's Digital radio
frequency memory
now that's similar to what the stingray
is that the FBI uses to to eavesdrop on
people's cell phones it basically takes
it takes the Digital radio frequency
signal from your cell phone copies it
and then pretends to be or from the cell
tower and then beams it and pretends to
be the cell tower by copies of the uh
the briefcase that they put somewhere
that allows them to intercept your
Transmissions without your knowledge it
needs to be a briefcase they can put
inside of a rock now a rock cool yeah I
will tell you if they are listening
um they gotta up their [__] game
because my cell phone uh malfunctions at
a rate that is unnatural and so if
you're going to invade my privacy at
least do it with quality Tech so you
don't disturb my ability to live a life
that's just my editorial comment on that
front
um
all right uh I disrupted your flow here
no that's fine man I was I was pretty
much done after the balloons well that's
another a lot of this is technology that
people aren't aware of and if they do
the research they're like holy crap you
could you could literally fake all this
stuff but then the the UFO people get
all mad at me because they're like well
you're just like every every UFO case
now you can just explain it away is in
terms of our technology so what if
aliens really do show up and and and
you're just over here saying it's laser
beams and and uh
Advanced drones that have Hypersonic
capabilities and you know well I would
push back on those people because a
we are dealing with a scenario in which
if those things that people are
observing are aliens who wish to be
observed they can settle the question
any day they want to right right
so you're either dealing with the aliens
are ineffectively hiding themselves from
us
um or you're dealing with aliens who can
settle the question as far as the radar
signatures that's a more interesting
answer than I was expecting my sense was
you know if the people who are doing the
projecting maybe from space of what
seemed to be objects moving at
improbable speeds without propulsion
mechanisms through our atmosphere uh
want to seed something into a radar that
is not a natural consequence of the
radar detecting something in the world
they could presumably do that too but
what you have proposed
is that there are Technologies which
allow the projection of a phony radar
signal which makes
perfect sense I will tell you I uh in my
graduate work I was a bat biologist I
worked on echolocating bats I did not
work on echolocation but nonetheless my
my bats were echolocators
and there's always a question about
whether or not an animal that has this
capacity can
put a signature in front of another
animal right like how sophisticated is
this and maybe in the case of bats it's
unlikely maybe it'd be more likely in
the case of something like uh you know
dolphins
um and you know to be honest I don't I
don't know that there's any evidence
that they can but the possibility of it
is something that's been on people's
minds for many decades right well we
have acoustic meta materials so what if
there's like a moth that has this the
amount of material
um of hairs on the or cilia on the back
of its you know
abdomen that that reflects the bats
radar uh sonar signals or something you
know well it it's actually very similar
to uh you know you correct me if I'm
wrong but I used to lecture on this the
the paint that is used on the stealth
bombers and Fighters is
um an extremely fragile material for
exactly the same reason that moths are
covered in this Soft Stuff which is
radar absorbing
um and so you know there's all sorts of
tricks that the uh the stealth
technology uses one of them is that it's
instead of being rounded where there's
always a tangent facing
uh the radar source
the you know because the angle of
incidence equals the angle of reflection
if you make a faceted aircraft then if
you aim a beam of something at it it
tends to reflect off in a non-useful
direction right you have to sense from
all over the place but in addition you
cover the thing with something that is
absorbent and much less of the energy
gets reflected back at all
so once again we have reproduced an
Insight that selection built into
creatures
um before before we knew anything about
it
right and and there's also it's also
responsible for the the chitin on
various mascara beetles because there's
ones that are silver there's ones that
are emerald green this ones are gold
um and that is all just a change of the
permeability and permittivity of the of
the chitin
manifolds and as a meta material really
I did not I did not know that
yeah it's it's super interesting there's
also a whole theory of that that they
can be used The Meta materials can be
used for anti-gravity so we have people
that are experimenting with those as
well I don't really understand how
anybody could be anti-gravity my
feelings no one's got anything to show
we've we've tried 50 we've had 70 plus
years of everything that the
government's tried a lot of the
Declassified stuff going back to the you
know the the 50s with um bonson labs and
bifilm brown effect at all the way to
the you know 80s with
um David alsiphon and Boeing and this
this idea that spin Tronics or NMR would
have something to do with it
um but that actually started in 1946
with the discovery of nuclear magnetic
resonance with Edward Mills Purcell who
actually headed the cia's project
rainbow which was the CIA study into
that exact they have the equation for
radar reflection and they've said how
can we minimize in know the radar return
signal from these things or how can we
how can we use Dr the other solution was
the drfm technology that copies the
radar signal and sends the the spoof
signal back with the with the data that
they want
um and that's more complicated and it's
interesting because that was developed
at a place called site four out at
Tonopah test range during the 1980s is
where they did all that they had a big
mock-up of the Soviet raid they built
rebuilt the Soviet radar system with
their exact frequencies and everything
and then figured out how to um counter
it and that's the kind of stuff that
they would they would do out there and
it's interesting that it was at a place
called site four because the only other
place we found was a site four where
they built the B2 Spirit bomber at plant
42 in Palmdale which is
um and the whole site four that bibles
are talked about I've never found any
evidence for anything at Papoose Lake in
fact it's a radioactive Wasteland that
this and it floods in the in the wet
season so
um it's it just it seems like a whole
big deliberate misdirection
um that is going on in the in the
mainstream especially with what happened
on Joe Rogan
um The Joe Rogan podcasts where they had
uh he got really sucked into that whole
Bob Lazar rabbit hole and never got
never seemed to get out of it you know
yeah well
um
you know uh I find Joe an extremely
reasonable guy
um and you know he says flat out that uh
he desperately wants the alien story to
be true and that that clouds his
judgment I must say I also desperately
want it to be true because
Not only would I be
um Beyond fascinated as a biologist to
have any insight into what life looks
like elsewhere in the universe but I
also as a humanitarian believe that we
are in
very deep trouble with our technology
and our rate of technological change and
it would be a godsend yeah if we could
get a piece of something you know well
if we could just you know it to the
extent that some alien race had found
its way to Earth
that means they've probably solved the
basic game theoretic puzzles that seem
to be putting us in such great danger
and if they you know let's put it this
way I'm willing to run the risk
of an alien race that is not
um favorable towards earthlings I find
that unlikely I think it's very unlikely
that there would be anything
um to take from us that would be worth
having they might be fascinated by us as
another example of life and they might
be interested in
uh you know bringing us in on some of
the deeper secrets of the universe so
that we might survive the next 150 years
I'm willing to take the risk of any of
those possibilities because frankly the
danger we pose to ourself is now
ourselves is now so great that
um while I'm I'm not giving up on us I
do think our best hope would be somebody
who's figured out these answers letting
us in on them
it's it's interesting um I want to
mention a couple things that relate to
this uh and I want to start with the one
of the last things that bibles are said
he changed his story actually he never
said this before The Joe Rogan podcast I
believe it was on where he said
that he believes now that these things
if there's a hanger full and he thinks
that they were from an archaeological
find that they were dug up and I thought
that was kind of interesting because you
know one of the only cases from history
that I think you can't explain with you
know Chinese lanterns or some other
types of Mis identification would be
like the 1561 Nuremberg case where they
said they literally thought they saw a
sky battle take place you have to wonder
if there's like type three and two
civilizations out there maybe there is a
Star Wars type battles that have
happened and you know some of that stuff
is debris that's floating around it's
asteroids some maybe some of that
stuff's Fallen to Earth and landed and
and you what would have happened over
history if say you know some the Roman
army found something like this where
would it where do you think it would be
today and where it would have ended up
it would have been deemed a holy Relic
and it would have been brought back to
the church and it would have been locked
away in the babatican basement vaults
for eternity and that's where it would
be today yeah it's funny you know
um this is this is almost the case with
Dinosaurs right right it was yeah that
material has been near the surface you
know found presumably by many people
over the course of history and
pre-history but nobody knew what to make
of it right the discovery that you know
what those creatures actually were is
relatively recent and so
um yeah you could imagine all kinds of
misfiling of of uh materials that made
no sense to the people who encountered
them because
frankly they didn't even know where they
lived in the universe at the time
um well yeah certainly the the
prevalence of dinosaur bones in the in
the geological record is is um something
you know more that shows up a lot more
than alien alien um debris or uh you
know spaceships parts from another
galaxy or anything like that it doesn't
exist as far as we know so
um and if it did it it's interesting
that
I don't know where that material will be
today but there's a couple people that
claim to have pieces of this stuff Gary
Nolan for one and and others so but all
right so again this would be it would be
nanotechnology I I would assume of uh
you know sophistication that would be
beyond anything that we know and again I
think that the coolest things I've seen
is the idea of meta materials and quasi
crystals and the whole idea of photonic
crystals and photonic circuits that
we're getting to a point with our
computer chips and our computer
technology that we're going to be able
to build
you know 5D memory crystals and and
things that we're our data storage
capabilities going to go through the
roof and our computational power usage
and also CPU size is going to um
just be
exponentially increased with the next
gen once we make that leap from
Electronics to spintronic photonic
devices you mean CPU capacity will be
increased
the power usage that we have to use
because you're now you're pushing
photons around which take a fraction of
the energy it costs to push electrons
around they don't produce nearly as much
heat waste you know the resistance
inside these you know photonic cavities
and computer uh circuits would be
astronomically lower than you know the
copper wiring and other yeah photons are
light as hell yeah yeah all right that
was a terrible pun uh hopefully you'll
forgive me and continue this
conversation but
okay so let me just figure out uh where
you live on this topic all right you
believe that uh alien races are
uh plausible
geometric equation it's almost certain
that that we're not alone I would say I
would agree
um
that Technologies which might allow us
to bend space or to utilize entanglement
in some way suggest that there probably
isn't an actual bar to Great
civilizations separated by what seemed
to be large distances
we also have to believe we have to like
push this boundary man this is our our
civilization and our survival depends on
it sure but but despite the fact that
you believe those things it sounds to me
like what you've said is you don't
believe
you believe that this is more likely a
psyop than uh an actual visitation that
we were the first time that they've done
something like this I mean you look back
to 1988 with UFO TV live they had this
whole
broadcast caught with the Aviary it was
called where they brought out all these
guys and cloak in Cloak and Dagger and
she didn't show their faces and had
voice mods on them and of course we know
all their names today and they've been
associated with you know distant UFO
disinformation and stuff like that one
of the guys is actually owl from The Av
areas was Hal put off which is
interesting and how put off does have a
history with psychological warfare or
operations he did that whole stint with
the men at steric Goats with Albert
stubble being and those guys that they
um in the book Psy spies by Jim Mars I
read all about it so he's got some
interesting history the stuff he did at
SRI International but he's also got some
interesting physics and and the whole
idea of this polarizable vacuum approach
to general relativity where you can if
you change the permeability and
permittivity of free space and between
you know things you then you can work
that those distances and perhaps those
other um variables and and change the
laws of general relativity without you
know violating Einstein
um because that's a big No-No in physics
um so so
um really interesting stuff that in in
the literature there but he you know
don't know if he got that idea on his
own because he he worked closely with a
lot of other interesting fellas like
um Bernard hash from Caltech who was
worked as a uh staff physicist for
Lockheed Martin from 1979 to 1999 and
did a lot of theoretical work for
Lockheed Martin on these you know
theoretical warp drives you know 19 late
in mid-1994 I think in 1994 is when
Miguel alcubiere published that warp
drive paper and the uh the community
kind of just went nuts you know so they
were like well well we're gonna have
people looking into this and they did
all right
so here's the question for you though
you
believe it is possible that we have been
or are being visited or will be
you do not buy as I don't the evidence
that is on the table because it all
seems to have a more rational
explanation that is terrestrial
what have you seen that gives you pause
that makes you think actually that one
might be more easily explained by aliens
and their technology visiting the Earth
if there's nothing there's nothing but
I'd be curious well if it's there's a
couple ones you just wonder if they're
real or not certain certain you know
things certain cases you know like this
one video that that was supposedly
um recorded of a a UFO flying over and
it make it instantly prints a crop
circle in a field and it was supposedly
captured on like uh you know a regular
camera although this I don't haven't
seen the chain of evidence or any other
any of the proof for that because it
really just looks like early you know
Advanced CGI or something that produces
it yeah
um you know certainly very hard to
accept anything that's just pixels you
know
you know I was super into this stuff
early on when I first got into it and I
I was convinced that it was not you know
like
that there might be you know another cut
there was like another cover-up and I
took that angle very strongly in a lot
of the research that I did because you
know people like Bob Lazar who sent me
down that rabbit hole like they're high
in a hanger out in the desert with nine
saucers in it I mean come on that that
that's enough to get anyone young kid
interested in in this stuff and the
potentials that it might hold and you
know it's interesting when you start
getting into the real physicists that
that didn't do you know work as senior
staff physicists for for Lockheed Martin
and you're like wow Lockheed Martin was
looking into inertial you know control
and also free energy systems and and
stuff like that it's it's
it's interesting
um but it's it's more interesting I find
than the fake stuff which is you know
the whole you know there's no proof for
any of that and the the element 115
thing is like you know it was a I could
just add numbers to the periodic table
and guess element 120 some 29 129 and
and say that it has anti-gravity where
is it it's been discovered it's and it's
not stable
in in anything more than you know a few
milliseconds and it's not anti-gravity
yet so we're still waiting and uh the
jury's still out and there's you know
NASA studied field propulsion in 1979
under you know Alan Holt and a number of
uh you know there's a number of other
studies that you know you can look to
and say like well they studied this
stuff they referenced NASA references uh
UFOs as being an inspiration for why
they did the study
you know so obviously NASA scientists
were taking some of this stuff seriously
and trying to look into it and and do
research into it but
I haven't seen direct evidence of
anything yet hard to that that's proves
it and then the physics that we do have
with that do look promising is you know
things like
um
laser etching lithography of quantum
dots you know laser etching Quantum dots
onto metal surfaces and and then
layering these meta materials that you
can create from laser the laser etchings
and the things that those will do and
then also layered graphene with other
types of you know borophene and other
types of um interesting two to
two-dimensional materials create some
really interesting effects that um we'd
really like to study more but again
these things are super expensive to to
to to play with basically well my
understanding is that is changing uh Jim
tor's lab seems to have come up with a
inexpensive process for Mass producing
uh graphene in a useful form
um
so and you know I actually know Jim a
little bit and uh I have nothing but
respect for the guys capacity in the
realm of nanotech it's incredible so
anyway there's no doubt
we are on the verge of many a material
Revolution where you know tiny amounts
of matter can be arranged in ways that
have extraordinary properties and
presumably any sufficiently advanced uh
race elsewhere in the universe would
have
encountered those things and leveraged
them in all kinds of ways that are hard
for us to imagine so
um but I want to go back because you
describe something
fascinating here which you know uh
strengthens my sense about who you are
and why I would listen to you on a topic
like this
you describe yourself as
um more credulous
uh with respect to
the visitation of Earth by aliens
earlier and the more you've studied and
learned the less you are convinced that
the evidence that they have been here
exists you haven't seen anything that
compels you I think that that's a very
powerful story for somebody who believes
that it is readily possible
to have convinced themselves out rather
than convinced yourself into the idea
that it has happened or is happening
you've gone the other direction and
that's exactly what I would want to see
I would want to see the scientific
skepticism
cause you to in fact realize uh that
there's a more likely explanation for
what we have so far seen
so you want to get into why I got to
that position or the best and I'll I'll
cap it off with the best evidence that
I've actually seen so far through my
study of you know trying to prove this
out and
you know everything is yep so
yeah I the thing is it's it's you get
burnt out because you if you really
believe too much in a case and then you
find out you start digging more and more
and eventually it loses its footing you
know you debate with it you debate it
with enough Skeptics that you realize
that you learn more about the case as
you debate it with more and more people
and and
engage more with Skeptics like you can't
just sit in an echo chamber and with a
bunch of people who agree with you and
you'll never get really anywhere and and
even if you do what's the point
um because you're just you're just
staying inside of a closed hole so that
kind of got me out of that and I
realized pretty early on that technology
was the way out of all this stuff in the
science really proving it out if you can
you know do an experiment you know if
that if you're saying that you have a
technology which can turn steel into
dust then show me and demonstrate it you
know build it and then show me how to do
it and how much energy it uses and all
the and everything else and uh
you know and then we can do it we can go
from there you know or show me
anti-gravity so yeah so we have 70 plus
years of the government studying this
stuff and I've I have a massive archive
that we've assembled of all the
different studies but you know after two
years of doing Apec and you know getting
guys like Ryan Ronald Evans on from
Project Green Glow over in the UK he was
on BBC like a week after he presented on
on our show and uh basically gave the
whole gave like the real deep you know
this wasn't like the BBC 10 minute video
coverage on it he presented for an hour
and then submitted to an hour q a where
we just grilled the guy on you know
asked him anything we wanted about this
this program that he worked on
um at over at
um Britain's Area 51 important down
um
really interesting stuff and they're
doing some really cool research over
there they have a super sensitive
um
Quantum gradiometer gravitometer it's
called it measures quantum gravity it
basically just detect any little
disturbance so if UFOs are flying around
it will be able to detect them
but not the first time again that that
what you find is that this
counterintelligence that have seeped in
and done things like the Aviary that I
talked about one of those guys was a guy
named Richard Doty and there's a
documentary I think anyone who gets into
UFOs should watch it's called Mirage Men
and it's a story of this guy named Paul
benowitz who is an amateur radio
operator and had a bunch of radio
equipment too close to
um an NSA surveillance operation and and
something that they were some top secret
programs that they were running out of
um what's the name of the Air Force Base
down in New Mexico there
um
anyways uh he was stumbled upon this and
got a little too close to it and so they
have signed this U.S Air Force OSI
office of special investigations agent
Richard Doty did the case and
plant Dodie befriended him and then
plant it was started planting stuff they
started beaming radio signals into his
stuff and made him feel like that he had
stumbled across the alien operation and
then it was the NSA talking to aliens
and it was this big thing and and and
made the guy go crazy actually Paul Paul
benowitz the true story and he actually
committed suicide because of all of it
and even after like they had thrown him
off the trail of it when he was going
off the deep end they had tried Dodie
said he had tried to approach him and
and tell him the truth
and he didn't want to believe it he was
so deep into the rabbit hole at that
point he didn't want to believe that you
know he he wanted to believe the that he
had stumbled across this big alien thing
rather than it was a you know a top
secret you know Air Force project that
they were and that they were trying to
throw him off the case
and and then it talks about other
operations like project plowshare was
one where they were doing underground
nuclear testing and then they wanted to
monitor some of the radiation effects
and the down Downstream
um river systems and and tat neighboring
towns and cities
and what they were doing to do that is
you know sampling some of the local
livestock like cattle and they were
moving the thyroid glands from the
cattle because of course thyroid has um
iodine uptake so when there's
radioactive iodine in the environment
from the you know off stream from this
nuke test it's going to get picked up by
your thyroid gland and so that's going
that's going to be the place they're
going to be able to detect it and
um so they were basically the military
was taking people's livestock cutting
out the thyroid glands and then to throw
them off this Trail they were you know
cutting out other organs and dropping
them from helicopters and doing and
sucking all the blood out and doing all
this weird stuff
um to throw them off the trail of what
they're really after the thyroid glands
for the radioactive iodine but they were
doing all this weird stuff and blaming
it on Aliens so that they didn't have to
pay the farmers for their cattle so
question about that
um
the radioactive iodine has a very short
half-life I think it's yeah days or
something like that so they were doing
this in the immediate aftermath of their
underground tests yeah they were testing
and and then they were blamed they were
doing the cattlemutulations to blame it
on Aliens and because some of the local
farmers were getting suspicious and they
were trying to throw them off the trail
apparently this is like and then of
course you take the other side of this
you know the the play Devil's Advocate
uh you know or conspiracies Advocate and
say oh well maybe the government created
this explanation just to cover up the
aliens doing this and right
yeah I mean and and this is one of the
problems with a landscape of secrecy is
that it actually throws a monkey wrench
into the normal use of Occam's razor
right because anytime you have something
in which a cover-up is an actual
functional piece of the thing
what is a cover-up well a cover-up is
something that attempts to create the
impression of the way some dots should
be connected that isn't the correct way
to connect them and so anyway again this
is why I have appreciated your work for
many years is that you you know my own
feeling is Occam's razor works even when
you're dealing with conspiratorial stuff
but it only works when you have all of
the information when you have a subset
especially a curated subset of the
information you have to be ready to see
a violation of Occam's razor and realize
that you know
that you know you're missing you're
missing evidence
um and so anyway yeah where's the
coverage Way Beyond that Beyond octon's
razor when you deal with a cover-up
because what you have is a an
institution which has control of 90 of
the mainstream media where they can
direct a message create a false movement
um prop up their fake fake leaders of
this false movement lead an entire
movement in the wrong direction
um ask if because you know you go back
to
um
you know Thomas pensions uh to quote
Thomas pension and gravity's rainbow if
they can get you asking the wrong
questions they don't have to worry about
the answers and
that that's the whole concept of the
game here is that they create a false
they prop up all these no-nothings with
the misinformation so they can put those
front and center create this movement
you know attitude that we're gonna knock
down the doors and and get the answers
to all this stuff but they asked the
wrong questions and then and then it
gets debunked and then everyone loses
hope and goes home and says you know
like oh maybe this was
there's nothing to this and then if
there is programs there they're not
they're not getting talked about and
they're also hyping everyone up but that
it's aliens and that we need to you know
get the government to disclose the truth
you know to bring out the saucers and
the aliens and and to bring it up but
what if that's not the case I don't we
don't have
a ton of we have some interesting
circumstantial evidence for that but we
don't have any direct evidence so the
circumstantial evidence is kind of
interesting you have this
well one is you have this repeat event
of
um
the balloons over Super Bowl weekend
they all get shot down you know blown
out of the sky with Sidewinder missiles
so there's nothing left and then they
can say like oh they vanished Without a
Trace and and we don't have anything
left to do but it was all you know spy
balloons and these Advanced balloon
technology and that's of course a repeat
of you know Roswell which they blame the
whole thing with uh the Alvarez you know
Alvarez the scientists who did all the
project Mogul balloon experiments for
the you know US military at the time you
know coming out and saying this was all
part of a really big weather balloon
train and radar reflectors that we were
using to track you know adopt you know
to do Doppler patterns in the clouds to
measure the wind patterns with the with
these balloons and um
you know this is all part of uh you know
our operation and some of them might
have been spy balloons too that we were
sending over as well even early back
then and that was the whole cover-up for
Roswell apparently but and then you have
things like
Von Neumann in October uh you know one
of the top Manhattan Project scientists
uh the the brain of of the Manhattan
Project essentially
um and he
comes up with the idea of Von Von
Neumann probes which are uh
self-replicating space probes probes
that can go out and make copies of
themselves and then go out and colonate
the Galaxy and make more copies and
share and send information
um back and forth It's essentially like
the a type three what we call type three
kardashev now
um
now did he just hear the rumors about
Roswell and the alien crash saucer and
come up with the idea on his own just in
his own brain or did he see something
and came up with that idea from that
also
arguable I say both ways
um
now the legend goes that whatever they
recovered at Roswell
um the
Air Force intelligence officer on the
scene Jesse Marcel later testified that
there was a debris switch and that it
was not of this Earth
which started a lot of these conspiracy
theories and rumors and of course we
know that the debris went to right Fort
um
uh Fort Worth first went to Fort Worth
Texas from Roswell which was the the
division the head of the first Army
Division and then from there raymie took
the Press uh photo with it in the press
conference saying it was just a weather
balloon and from there apparently that
that was where the debris switch took
place and that the real material went to
Wright-Patterson Air Force Base on
another flight
and that it was received at
Wright-Patterson and stored in a place
um
I don't know if it was Hangar 18 at
Wright-Patterson I think it was Hangar
18 at the first
um at Roswell
um getting the date the the important
details mixed up but interesting that in
um Battelle Memorial Institute which is
in Columbus Ohio which is 45 minutes
from Dayton Ohio where Wright-Patterson
is they did a study um into the
Metallurgy of nitinol
um basically nickel nickel Alloys they
were looking into titanium Alloys sorry
titanium Alloys and they had a whole
bunch of different different titanium
Alloys but the focus on nickel Alloys
was like three pages
um when the other ones were just a page
each and so they were really looking at
nickel titanium Alloys back then in 1949
for some reason and this was of course a
decade before nitinol wire was
discovered at Naval Ordnance Research
Laboratories and one of the interesting
things about the the Roswell debris that
all these Witnesses if you go back to
the original witness testimony they
described this memory foil of this this
Memory Metal
um that was a wove and they said they
said people who worked with this stuff
said that it was like a woven mesh
fabric on the quantum level and that's
why they said that it couldn't have been
man-made back then it was just way too
complex of a material and no one's ever
been able to reproduce a piece of that
material or or show that it's real but I
think the stories of it were interesting
enough to to wonder why you know they
were looking into ways to apparently you
couldn't cut or break the stuff it was
really really hard and
um
and really durable and
so right in this Battelle study they
have the scientists working on this um
carbon tetrachloride method where they
dissolved this stuff and and
um
chlorine carbon tetrachloride
and then measure the off gases to
determine the composition
so they have these real ways of really
complex ways of analyzing substances
that would might be indestructible so to
speak in in 1949 which is interesting
um but most interesting thing is it was
the the research was under the director
of this guy Howard C cross who came up
in this Pentacle memorandum that was
found in J Allen heineck's notes Jalen
heineck was the scientist that the U.S
Air Force hired to had the Project Blue
Book investigation from you know
1958 I think till 68
um maybe 55 it was
if I'm correct
um I might be getting the dates wrong
but yeah the Project Blue book study
apparently there was two Project Blue
books there was a second Project Blue
Book which dealt with this Metallurgy
side of actual had access to actual
materials and that was directed by
Howard C Cross of Patel and there were a
number of other interesting names on
that list who I've never been able to
really track down and find any solid
information on the on any of those
people
um looking through just conventional
records if there's records on them it's
at Patel or somewhere else
or whoever was involved in it but
I thought that was interesting
um because if there was an operation
Patel would be the place that would do
it it's a quasi-governmental
organization it's
um
you know what editor Mitchell described
and where these things were held in an
interview he apparently knew something
about it or Gordon Cooper I'm not sure
which one of them but anyways Patel
is an interesting an interesting
organization because it manages all of
our National Labs so Los Alamos Oak
Ridge they're all under the management
directorship of Patel so if you want to
control science in this country
you could do it easily through a
quasi-governmental organization like
Patel they would have the power and
leverage to be able to You Know cover up
um
a UFO thing or hold on be a container so
to speak for for
um a UFO file or something like of this
nature if it exists if there's a the
other uh container that we know of that
may have existed was actually uncovered
by a senator Barry Goldwater I who was
told about this
um it was allegedly a blue a blue room
it's called the Blue Room at
Wright-Patterson and that
the blue room is where they store
um all the
artifacts of Unknown Origin
apparently whether that's Russian or
Chinese or or what have you
um so there's
you know
there's speculation about that you know
I don't know for sure I I'm curious I'd
certainly like to believe that there's a
blue room and that they have pieces of
alien technology in there that you know
they're not releasing to the public
because you know
what happens when you know uh what
happens when Al Qaeda gets a hold of
free energy technology you know it's and
anti-gravity and warp drive it's it's
not going to be pretty so it I I can
understand why they they may want to
keep that stuff classified if it if it
does exist but at the same time if if we
had all if everyone had it and and they
just you know
I don't know at the same time I think
that even if they did release it the
material science end of this is
sufficiently so far Advanced that it
sets us a high enough bar that you can't
really reach that bar without um some
serious International collaboration so I
I really doubt that if they did disclose
it or release the release it that a
rogue group would be even be able to
like even Mao say tongue you know
wouldn't be able to I mean even you know
Kim Jong-un wouldn't be able to you know
build this stuff without you know some
serious collaboration I think it's going
to take a a serious International
collaboration and effort to to develop
photonics technology and warp drive
technology and all in this next
revolution in science and physics that's
coming so again just to be just to be
clear what you're saying is there may or
may not be a blue room it may or may not
contain alien Tech so far there's no
reason to believe that it does that you
have seen
um but if it did there would be the
expectation that it you you offer a more
generous interpretation of why it would
not be shared
um my sense is that it given the levels
of governmental corruption that we have
now seen
it is hard for me to imagine uh that the
first instinct of at least some of the
people who would have had access
wouldn't be to privatize it for uh their
own profit
which would then necessitate a cover
story of why it wasn't being shared
um right this is the plot to all the um
Disney's Witch Mountain films where it's
always some rich billionaire that wants
to get a hold of that technology and
leverage it yeah yeah I would agree yeah
all right
um well that's all very interesting and
uh
matches my own sense I have yet to see
the thing that will cause me to jump and
the other thing right is is that the
people that they put in charge of of
these things are very often Uber
religious you know Christian types who
are who and they convince them that that
this is demons you know so they have to
lock these demons away from you know
normal societies and and this is sort of
the the use of a religious philosophy I
think and some of the um in some of
these institutions to keep this because
it seems like a lot of the people who
I've seen or are these people that are
convinced that it's demons and or you
know and and that's their interpretation
of it they don't want to go beyond that
and and they're happy with that
explanation and uh
but you know again I think I seem to
think that anything outside of uh the
belief system of um Dogma or official
you know dumb is is deemed demons in in
this day and age or Conspiracy Theory
what happened actually that brings me to
something I wanted to recover from
something you said earlier in the
podcast
uh and forgive me it's now been long
enough it's going to be hard for me to
recover exactly what you said but yeah
we were talking about the
um
the mixture the you know the getting
people to ask the wrong questions and
what I have seen you know if I look out
at um the the intellectuals of the day
many of them seem to have a smug
and at the same time I think completely
inexplicable
belief that conspiracies are not worth
worrying about and many of them have a
rationalization for why you don't have
to worry about them you know they're
rare and so there's some sort of
percentage argument I don't know but the
whole thing
strikes me as the product of a
psychological operation
that in effect if what you did is you
know first of all I think those who
conspire at a sophisticated level have
learned certain tricks one of them is
that you release
real information fused with garbage yeah
and what this does is it produces a an
experience that is near Universal where
people who begin to follow one of these
rabbit holes because there's something
real to be discovered
Embrace some piece of garbage they get
burned and it's basically like a dog
being swatted on the nose with a
newspaper every time it you know
puts its it snouts somewhere they learn
not to do it and so the basic point is
why would intellectuals who know full
well that conspiracies have been a
permanent feature of history
from the beginning
why would they Embrace a position that
is in effect a non-starter conspiracies
aren't worth worrying about
um if that makes no sense well because
they're behaving like dogs
who every time they've uh contemplated a
conspiracy have had their nose swatted
and so they've learned not to do it and
they're now explaining to themselves why
it's not worth doing which is very
destructive because of course it Fosters
conspiracy it creates a cloak for it in
which it can operate well what we've
seen during covet is we've seen
conspiracies operating almost in plain
sight right conspiracies to suppress
information
conspiracies to shape people's uh
understanding to exploit their fears and
even the revelation of it doesn't cause
it to break and cause us to you know
pursue an explanation of who did it and
why and what their real motives might
have been
um so anyway I'm looking at a population
that looks like
it was trained not to ask the right
questions which dovetails very well with
what you had put on the table yeah yeah
it's it's also funny because who are
they asking the questions to because the
ultimate
um to quote Robbie Graham the ultimate
irony of the disclosure movement is that
it deeply distrusts official dumb while
simultaneously looking to official them
for the truth and by imagining all
answers to the UFO mystery to be out of
public reach deep in the bowels of the
National Security State the disclosure
movement actually places power into the
hands of official them while
disempowering the individual
and I think that's a that's profound
because who does the military look to
when they need answers well they well
for Project Blue Book they hired who J
Allen heineck who was Jaylen heineck he
was a scientist this guy like me who was
like I'm super interested in UFOs and
I've already studied this
um you know a debt for a decade more
without pay and I'd be happy to study
for the government you know with pay if
uh if I could just get you know if I
just knew the right people I guess well
I've wondered about this from a
different perspective you know I wonder
why there aren't
maybe there are and I'm just not aware
of them but it seems to me
that the idea of you know demanding that
the government cough up the information
about the aliens
uh ought to be coupled with and it at
least as uh prominent and impulse to
just contact the aliens directly like
why are people
not bypassing the government and saying
actually you can't trust those people
um why don't you come talk to some folks
who are actually up to the challenge why
is there no sign private scientific
Institute with a beam that it's pointing
up into the you know into the sky with
an invitation to actually talk science
and uh help Humanity out of its mess
right we could go to the very large
array down in New Mexico where the you
know the big saddle uh radio satellite
telescope array and uh just set up a
beam in the center of that thing with a
landing pad and and uh it would be like
you know contact seti yeah how about
even just help
we could use some help we're at that
stage of history that undoubtedly if you
exist you know happens where we are a
huge danger to ourselves and our
leadership is not up to the challenge
you would think um that we could at
least put out you know it would be
inexpensive to invite the aliens who
very well may not exist uh in near
proximity at all but if they do you know
why do why are we
trusting the governments to talk to them
I don't trust the governments to do
anything else at this point I've seen
too much you know why would we trust
them at all in fact if if it came out
and the government's admitted to this or
said anything about it I would distrust
that immediately
yeah I'm distrusted immediately exactly
the aliens are suffering from the
distrustworthiness of government uh
which might be impacting their ability
to actually talk to some of us folks
down here who um uh would be in a better
position to do it well
I just I'm just astounded by the people
that the two individuals that the
Pentagon put in front of Congress for
those hearings and and how
just clueless they were and
underprepared of and and I feel like the
whole thing is a set up misdirection
where they they can get they can post up
their false front
um and again this is like the idea of uh
the pseudo gang it's called
um you know like in if you watch Life of
Brian where they had the Judean People's
front and then the people's front of
Judea this counter organization of a
similar name and and you pretend to be
the original organization and then cause
a bunch of trouble so that everyone
hates your organization by
um you know and that's the idea is that
they can create they can put a bunch of
um crap out there with fake scientists
fake whistleblowers and fake videos get
it all debunked where they can introduce
this video and and say and then it gets
debunked where they can literally find
the star pattern in the charts and say
look look it's a it's a triangular
aperture lens it's creating the bokeh
effect and you're not admitting to this
and and yet he's still trying to hammer
down that door it that's a psyop that's
a psyop because we have such better
evidence anyone who wants to look into
this thing a little bit could find that
and no much better questions to ask but
when these the people that are leading
in the and the information that's being
you know presented you're not going to
get the any answers are you the answers
you're going to get are going to be the
wrong ones and it's and I think that
there's a lot of that going on right now
with regards to this because
there is credible information that at
least from what I found for
what we're working on that when the
Public's not being told about and I
think it's more important what's not
being talked about than what is in in
with regards to this subject so yeah
that's that's fascinating unfortunately
I have seen that pattern uh with covid
where
the they create a bunch of fake doctors
right and then they'll create these fake
PHD profiles on Twitter and you'll
follow them thinking it's real
information and then they'll start
inserting a lot of bad information with
it I saw that that's that's certainly
true something has created false
profiles but even worse there are
you know there is a discussion of people
who have decided to pay the price of not
staying on narrative and that discussion
has disagreement within it and then
there's the official discussion which
pretends to have disagreement within it
over questions that are effectively
settled I mean why are we
still I mean look you can take your kid
and you can get them an mRNA vaccine
for covid
that doesn't make any sense right the
fact that the current version of covet
isn't especially threatening that it
doesn't threaten children that we do
have Adverse Events
it doesn't there is no rational argument
for that and yet what we have in the
doctor's office and in the halls of
Congress and everywhere else is the
pretense that there is a rational
argument which it's hard to even imagine
what it would sound like right we're
just there's too much evidence now that
that argument is dead in the water and
yet
you know actual needles are being put
into actual arms that they should never
be
um so anyway there's something about the
way the degree to which official them is
willing to pretend that an argument is
viable you know in the case of the uaps
you're describing people who
um aren't expert being
questioned as if they were and revealing
themselves to be foolish but the point
is as you say that is the diagnosis of a
psyop right that the purpose of such a
thing the purpose of querying people who
are not experts
there's many different types of psyops
so like this bait and switch where they
you know you bait them with what they
think is you know the golden
whistleblower but you switch it out for
a fake then there's the straw man where
you're presenting this is like well this
is a UFO researcher and or this is a
this is a conspiracy theorist and this
is what they believe where you you you
create a straw man version of that then
you can debunk the straw man where you
you can keep those arguments in within a
context where you can actually you know
debate them like
I don't know I can go into many examples
but I don't know
well I mean I do think
um before we close this discussion out
uh it is worth saying I first became
aware of you not in the UFO UAP context
but I first became aware of you in the
context of conspiracy
I would call them hypotheses I think we
do ourselves a disservice to refer to
them as conspiracy theories that that's
in fact part of the psyop that causes us
to look away but in any case
um there are many conspiracies we have
to be
forever Vigilant because the incentive
for people to conspire and take
advantage of us is
it's not going anywhere
that said the majority of hypotheses in
the area of conspiracy are simply wrong
and so what one needs is a toolkit
for searching that landscape for
useful information
without falling victim to either a
reflexive Embrace of conspiracies or
equally as bad a reflexive rejection of
the idea of conspiracy which may solve
the problem of you know you looking good
to your friends at the cocktail party
but it puts us all in much greater
danger of actual conspiracies succeeding
and so the question is how does one
address that and my from before I uh had
discovered your work
uh I had concluded that the right
toolkit with science that one has to be
aware you don't have all the information
and one has to navigate very cautiously
but nonetheless you can for example
study not just that but you also have to
be aware that someone is actively trying
to hide the real information from you
and present the The Narrative that's
being presented in the mainstream public
I almost like immediately assume is
false always because if that's what's
always being put out there it's the
cover story and the real information is
always being actively hidden and I find
that in search engine that one of the
biggest tool tool kits I can tell people
is I I use Yahoo video search now
because it it's like the back end
algorithm for how YouTube search
algorithm used to work before they fixed
it so that you can no longer find what
you're looking for if this if it's a
conspiracy like I swear like they have
like a tag on real information
um the if you start talking about real
information on your video
it just doesn't it doesn't show up in
the searches anymore oh believe me I uh
our channel has uh clearly been flagged
in a way absolutely I watched I watched
it you guys were like getting twice the
views on the live streams and the and
and then yeah and then they they've
created the the doldrums whether that's
actual whether they actually are hiding
us from the public or whether they are
uh pretending that we're reaching fewer
people in order to dissuade advertisers
I don't know what they're doing but
um it is clear that you know it's more
than a thumb on the scale it's a
freaking elephant on the scale
um and you know it has its impact which
hasn't changed what we do but
um but nonetheless it does exist it's
part of some mechanism to prevent
certain things from being discussed in
places where they can be heard
um but that does raise a question I I do
want to talk to you about
the
fact of the desperate need I would say
the vacuum of people who responsibly
deal with questions of collusion
um something that I think you do
exceedingly well I don't know what the
ratio is between conspiracies that you
have concluded are real and uh
conspiracies that you have debunked but
you have certainly debunked far more uh
conspiratorial ideas than you have
embraced
it shows the same skeptical Instinct
that people have seen in this podcast
with respect to uaps I mean you you call
yourself alien scientist you're
certainly uh open to and excited for the
idea of alien contact but it doesn't
cause you to embrace things that are not
supported by evidence
right so in any case do you want to say
anything about
um
how you have engaged questions of
conspiracy and and what you've learned
about that General topic
well uh it's certainly interesting to
see the change in a lot of you know
because I had a lot of family members
and friends that had you know for years
said you know you're going You're like
crazy some of the stuff you talk about
and everything
and in the last two years I've had so
many people like come back and say you
know what you you were like I'm starting
I'm gonna start listening to you now
because everything you've been calling
it's like it's like I have a
I can predict the future or something
because it's you know I'm saying that
you know you have a group of people that
I've been watching that have done
a lot of things that are connected to
and a lot of these pieces are connected
uh you know let's talk about Iran Contra
Scandal for example right the closing
statement that Daniel anyway is senator
from Hawaii
um said at the the end of the Iran
Contra hearings is that there exists a
shadowy government with its own Air
Force its own Navy its own fundraising
mechanisms and the ability to pursue its
own ideas of the national interest free
from all checks and balances and free
from the law itself
when you look into the group that was
connected to Iran Contra and you realize
that you you start tracing these people
through a lot of bad this it's a bad
apples group and this is a it's parts of
the agencies that have gone Rogue over
the years and were never reeled back in
there's they've they've gone really
Rogue and and been involved in a whole
host of of nasty and uh really devious
things and and now we are talking about
something that must have been passed
from one generation of Rogue entities to
another right we have I mean this is one
of the things that is always the most
troubling it's it's hard to detect but
the most troubling thing in the
landscape of responsible conspiracy
hypothesis testing is that you find that
things like
the Kennedy assassination
are connected in strange ways to things
like the Watergate break-in yes yes
right yes Frank Sturgis and E Howard
hunt and uh they were like the they look
just like the uh the tramps that were
arrested in Dealey Plaza and later
released they were found in a train car
and then e Howard hunt on his deathbed
said he was a you know benchwarmer on
the assassination and and details like
that and then e Howard Hunt's lawyer
saying that oh what's the big picture
and that him saying that e Howard hunt
told his lawyer that it was uh that
they're hiding alien technology that was
another interesting uh thing that came
out of e Howard Hunt's lawyer that the
big thing that that this is all about is
that you know he was gonna bla JFK was
gonna blab about the alien technology
apparently and that he had told Marilyn
Monroe about it and that Marilyn Monroe
was assassinated along with her
girlfriend Dorothy kilgallon who was the
newspaper reporter that was writing the
her last interview that she did was with
Jack Ruby
wait what
Dorothy kilgallon her last interview
that she did was with Jack Ruby it never
got published and she and she wound up
dead before that published all right
that's a connection I didn't know
um yeah so but I didn't know about uh e
Howard hunt and the hobos arrested uh
outside of Dealey Plaza yeah the tramps
there's a there's a interesting suspects
they look like some CIA guys that were
dressed like hobos and um certainly
Bearer resemblance to uh
uh Frank Sturgis e Howard hunt and
I think Gary Campbell uh Campbell
um
and of course the fact that people
Bearer resemblance doesn't tell you
anything uh yeah there's been a lot of
misidentifications and other people like
say it was Chauncey Holt and and another
a number of other people that have uh
Woody Harrelson's dad he's at one point
was uh an allegation of that but there's
there's also yeah you look at the
photography and the stuff that people
have pulled out of there like the the
merry Mormon photograph and the badge
man you know there's the whole theory
that it was a Dallas police officer uh
uh one of the Dallas police officers on
the grassy knoll that took the shot but
what we can say
for factually certain is that in the
investigation of Watergate
um the assassination of JFK is mentioned
as if there is a connection and there is
a
effort to obscure it and in other words
that that Avenue is not taken we do not
find out what the connection is yeah
that was uh from the the Nixon tapes
right where he talks about the whole Bay
of Pigs thing and says we better not get
into that yeah yeah and the Bay of Pigs
thing was the Kennedy assassination of
course the Bay of Pigs was a nicknamed
operation Zapata yep
oil company was George H.W Bush's
company
and um they had used the platforms the
Scorpion platform as the staging
operation for the Bay of Pigs invasion
and
um that's why it was nicknamed operation
Zapata well back to the whole issue of
the Dallas police force those a lot of
the Dallas police officers used to hang
out at Jack Ruby's Club the carousel
Club in in in Dallas apparently and one
of them uh the guy was a guy named
Roscoe white who looked just like JFK
um no wait no wait Tippett was the one
that looked like JFK yeah the one that
got shot he looked like JFK and there's
a conspiracy that he was the body double
and that they needed to make was he am I
incorrect that his nickname
he looked so much like him
um yeah but one of the other police
officers was Roscoe white and Roscoe
white was in the Civil Air Patrol and he
was a platoon buddy with Lee Harvey
Oswald and he was also in the Marines at
station at atsugi Air Force Base which
is where the YouTube spy plane flights
were flown out of there's all these
interesting connections um one uh you
got to read Crossfire by Jim Mars
um it was a really good real good early
book on it and also family of Secrets by
Russ Baker he he was uh he really nailed
down a lot of other interesting
connections on the whole JFK
assassination for me where I was just
like you know this is just too deep in
the fact that it's we're here 70 years
later and they still won't release the
files on George Jones
um and that's just that's just suspect
right there um and the whole issue with
George Jones apparently he was at the
Ambassador Hotel the night that RFK was
assassinated too alongside David Sanchez
Morales and um Gordon Campbell
so yep the uh that's the thing is they
have uh effectively trained people not
to go down these rabbit holes because if
you go down these rabbit holes you do
find the number of connections is
improbably large
um it's it's really quite remarkable but
actually okay now that we've both
um taken the risk of exposing that we
are not
um we are not of the mindset that
conspiracies are so unlikely
to occur that we won't entertain them
right some people will view that as an
indictment of our capacity to think
and I would just I would ask you this
um
maybe you can ask them to debate me and
you could host it I I was I was thinking
along the same lines
um you'd be willing I know that you have
offered in the past but you're still
willing to debate
um conspiracy Skeptics
yeah absolutely
um so I happen I'm friends with Michael
Shermer I quite like him
um yeah he's he's a skeptic on on uh all
of these uh conspiratorial topics you'd
be willing to debate him on Dark Horse
yeah absolutely I I went on Mick West's
show
um two years ago I maybe I should uh get
Mick Weston and do a re-uh a revisit of
his show at some point too man I I
that's that's a good idea okay well cool
I I would love to see it um frankly I
think
the place that we are with respect to
collusion is very unhealthy you cannot
have a functional complex society like
ours and reflexively reject the idea of
collusion what you have to do is
actually be vigilant about figuring out
where it has occurred so that you can
drive the cost of colluding up too high
to contemplate and reduce the amount of
collusion that takes place which is you
know it's the opposite of where we are
we've built a uh we've built a cloak for
those who would conspire against us by
pretending that it is sophisticated to
ignore the possibility
right yeah and ignore the prosecution of
people that you know should have been
prosecuted for even earlier crimes
before the ones that they were you know
uh still committing you know free free
of even the slightest bit of scrutiny
it's it's kind of uh
it's kind of crazy
um what's going on in today's day and
age and I think it's it's more than
welcome now that in the in this
environment where we're waking up to the
possibility that wow large-scale
conspiracies can exist where you can
have a large number of you know
scientists or academics or doctors
um persuaded through means of you know
also it I think it's important what you
you talked about I think on the last
podcast or the one before you did where
you talk about incentivized you know you
the where the people in the OR
individuals are incentivized to go along
with the narrative and they're
incentivized not to speak out against
the narrative
um on an individual basis and and this
is this is a key part of how propaganda
works and that's why
um bernay's you know titled his book
crystallizing public opinion because
it's about this crystallization in order
to have a crystal you need a unit cell
and that unit cell needs to be motivated
by you know the forces acting upon it
which are the incentives
yep that's very well put
um the fact is you can manipulate an
arbitrarily large number of people
um with a relatively simple modification
of incentives and in fact you produce
exactly what we've seen uh over covet
and presumably in all the previous cases
where you've got a tiny number of people
who
are built around a different
architecture such that they are mostly
or completely insensitive to the normal
incentives and those people immediately
start looking around and saying well
wait a minute none of this adds up and
then you just have a wall of people
insisting on things that obviously
aren't true on the basis that they have
all individually detected their
incentives and are following them
whether they understand that that's what
they're doing or not whether they're you
know collaborators or useful idiots the
point is it's if if if you're using
consensus
in order to figure out what's likely to
be true a consensus of experts or a
consensus of the public then you are
very easily manipulated because a
consensus can be arranged simply by
shuffling incentives so that most people
will respond to them
one of the things they did with the JFK
assassination is they did not readily
release the Zapruder film to the public
what they instead did is they let a
Dallas news reporter by the name of Dan
Brown rather
tell the public what was on the contents
of the zipruder film and from Dan Rather
his incentive was hey I'm a young
reporter trying to make a name for
myself and these guys promised me I'm a
made man if I just sell their story for
them
and it's completely shocking because so
I don't think most people know this
piece of the story right we all because
we've seen the superuder film many times
have the sense that it's been around
from the beginning right the point is it
was briefly shown and then Dan Rather
installs whatever whether he is a useful
idiot or uh it was only shown to Dan
Rather and Dan Rather told the public
what what the first time it was shown on
television was 1968 I believe uh no wait
no maybe even later than that years
later
um I have to look that up that's a good
point because it wasn't until it wasn't
until I think a decade later it wasn't
until like the 70s or something so what
the public had was Dan Rather describing
and uh even mimicking the motion of the
president
and in exact in perfect contradiction of
what is shown on the film
I think it was like 78 that Geraldo
showed it on TV for the first time and
not right yeah
huh but what so what we have is
effectively a false memory
installed in the public on the basis of
a seemingly reliable source reporting
what he's seen and saying things that we
can now compare to the film and can
understand very simply are just false
right
yeah no it's a it's a it's very striking
and uh in terms of
uh revealing how a False Consensus is
built it is a a truly remarkable piece
of evidence
it's the anatomy of a psyop yeah
and uh
yeah I think it's I think uh I think the
public can't handle the truth and if
there's anyone uh that will die by the
by the revealing of the truth and I say
let them die
well I will I will go a different route
and I will say a those who would collude
against our knowledge always come up
with some excuse where it's in our
interest not to know the truth and you
know I'm sure some people can't handle
the truth I know that many of us can but
what I know for certain is that
um
authorities cannot handle the power to
decide when we are entitled to know the
truth
they're you know in a in a better
Society they might be able to but our
society is so corrupt
that frankly
um the truth must come out because what
we've been sold is uh closer to the
Matrix
right it's more fiction than reality and
uh everything is at stake including life
and limb clearly
yeah I just don't understand how the
intelligence agencies who who call
themselves intelligent
um can can
live with the fact that at the end of
the day their their job is to lie to
people and and control people's minds
through what the information that they
have exposure to and and don't and
that's it seems to be the name a lot of
the games of counterintelligence anyway
um rather than just pure people that
working in just in collecting
intelligence and spying directly but the
whole idea of this counterintelligence
that there are people that their job is
to
lie to you and make sure that you're
misdirected and that
your perception is managed
um
you're you're you won't even ask to be
able to ask the right questions to get
to the truth so it's it's
that's the place to be man but and I I
can't imagine the people that want to be
on that side of that and want to make
money and be paid and live with
themselves doing that for a job every
day where you're just like all right I
wanna I wanna disinform people I don't
want to bring Humanity up I gotta I
gotta be that boot that Stomps them down
as as you know further and further into
the ground so that you know my bosses
can stand up just that inch higher off
their you know
yeah uh they've they have lost any right
to manage I mean not that they had any
right to manage public perception but um
whatever limited interest there might be
in
uh controlling information they have so
abused that uh that privilege that it
certainly does not exist at this point
it's like I Heard lots of kids when I
was younger who wanted to grow up and
become teachers but none that wanted to
do the opposite of what teachers do to
anti-teach yeah agreed
[Music]
all right well uh
Jeremy where can people find you
so YouTube alien scientist is my channel
I go live periodically you can reach me
at the alienscientist gmail.com one word
if you want to email me I also have a
website alienscientist.com you can go
and contact me maybe through there and
reach out and I'm also on Twitter at
alien underbar scientist
so all right feel free to reach out
anywhere one of those platforms
fantastic well I really appreciate you
joining me this has been very
enlightening and uh hopefully real
honest to goodness aliens will find
their way here and bypass the government
and talk to some of the few adults who
are still running around on this planet
I like your idea of the the signal we
got I gotta start putting that out and
yeah all right we'll pass the government
what do you need them for yeah for them
any more than they have already
empowered themselves on our behalf with
our tax dollars exactly our scientists
all right well it's been a real pleasure
and uh good luck and hopefully uh
Michael Shermer or someone else will
take you up on your offer
awesome thank you for hosting me Brett
you're an awesome podcast be well
everyone
foreign